hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast this is the sixth in a series of
live streams with dr. Heather Hahn
sitting as always to my right we have
some interesting things to discuss with
you today and it is in some sense an
unusual podcast we will start with
Corrections and then we will get to the
part that is in many ways much more
personal I should also add that we are
working on technical aspects of the
podcast and so anyway this is a painful
process we are discovering all sorts of
wrinkles that need to be ironed out of
our system hopefully we will have fewer
dropped frames today and better
continuity with the sound I will try to
remember to speak into the microphone
which sometimes I don't do when I'm
looking at my lovely wife so if you have
other observations that we ought to know
about please don't be shy about sharing
them and we will attempt to refine this
process as we go all right
as far as Corrections go we have a few
things to discuss first I had a number
of people tell me that we had it wrong
with respect to whether or not urine is
sanitary and I would have to go back and
look at exactly what we said sterile was
the word that we used sterile okay so I
think the problem here there is a
correction that needs to be made which
is that it certainly can't be considered
sterile there are in fact things that
are transmitted in urine they tend to be
difficult to transmit that way but they
have been cultured by people who have
looked for it it's to say there is
bacterial load in your and there's
bacteria in the bladder at some point it
was imagined that maybe there wasn't but
and and there's more bacteria in the
bladder and urine of people with current
urinary tract infections but there's
always some bacteria in even the
healthiest urine the the issue though
comes down to one of extremophiles and
evolution so while urine is not sterile
it does have some sanitizing properties
by virtue of the high salt content
and it is not that things cannot adapt
to the high salt content clearly urinary
tract infections manage it but it is
difficult to evolve those things and to
the extent that things evolve resistance
to extreme environments they have a
difficult time with normal environment
so there's a trade-off there and this
explains why was the mass I who utilized
cow urine to wash their hands there is
some sanitizing capacity there so it's a
partial correction in that case and it's
certainly more more useful as a
sanitizer than any other bodily
excretion I can stand out Wow
okay well I mean I'm gonna yes you could
go gross with that but you could also
say okay spit to spit work now right and
you know anything blood no CC is
obviously not right okay good
second some folks challenged me I I was
asked what sort of preparatory materials
did I leave when we moved out of Olympia
and to Portland and I mentioned off the
top of my head
compressed air and the tools that go
with it and I had said that this could
be useful in the event of a collapse
scenario and many people said it's a
terrible idea it's too hard to generate
the pressure and to an extent they're
right and in fact we have switched over
to battery-powered tools which in many
scenarios are just simply so far
superior to air powered tools if the
power goes out that it's no contest but
I would point out that there are many
different collapse scenarios and
battery-powered tools are great if what
you have is a short-term collapse
scenario where things go back to normal
after a few months let's say in the
event that civilization actually came
apart your batteries would die your
tools would become useless and there'd
be no way to power them alternatively so
it really depends on what scenario
you're preparing for and one of the
difficult things for people who are
interested in preparing for all sorts of
unforeseen outcomes is trying to figure
out what the kit is that you want to
assemble that covers you for the maximum
number of scenarios and so
that are belt-driven and can therefore
be driven by something like a bicycle
are desirable from that perspective even
if they're not ideal from the
perspective of actually the amount of
work it takes to get power out of the
tools all right third thing has to do
with smallpox blankets and I said that
the stories about smallpox blankets
being delivered to natives of the new
world were apocryphal and indeed they
are when it comes to the conquistadors
there are a couple of credible instances
where this took place on the American
frontier where it is more often invoked
it was apparently not a widespread
practice it's not that this was
something that accounted for the massive
outbreak of smallpox across native
populations that was just simply the
confrontation between this novel
pathogen and a population that had no
evolutionary preparedness for it but
nonetheless there are a couple of
credible instances it's well worth
looking into and the final correction
though I've got a few oh wow I have one
more and then whatever list you have the
final one has to do with the focus of
the last live stream was on the question
of whether or not hypoxia and depletion
of iron and porphyrin from hemoglobin
was more credibly the cause of the
symptoms in the kovat 19 then is a
simple viral pneumonia and I don't have
a correction here I think what we said
turns out to be important but what it
has emerged is a tension between doctors
who are seeing different things and we
have doctors who are seeing the the
failure of the blood to transport oxygen
as a primary driving force and there are
other doctors who say no in fact this
really does look like pneumonia and the
piece of evidence that I heard marshaled
against the hypoxia argument or the
primary hypoxia argument was that the
dissolved oxygen in the plasma plasma is
the blood absent the cells the plasma
doesn't carry very much oxygen but it
carries some
and we're it's simply the failure of
hemoglobin to be transporting oxygen you
would expect the plasma oxygen levels to
be normal and in fact they are not
normal in the case of some of the
doctors who are arguing against the
hypoxia as the the driving force here
and the point is that is more consistent
with oxygen failing to cross from the
lungs into the bloodstream rather than
the blood failing to carry oxygen yeah
that's a great illustration of a
prediction that would appear to and not
necessarily falsify but run counter to
what it was that we were talking about
right although the final thing I'll say
about it is that these two things are
not mutually exclusive and they're not
mutually exclusive in two ways one it
could be that kovat 19 causes both
problems right and so to decide that one
is not the cause and the other is is a
mistake in either case which is it's it
won't always be the case of course that
you can have two hypotheses that aren't
mutually exclusive and it is cleaner
when we have ones that are such that
when you falsify one whichever one is
left standing is the most likely to be
true but in this case there's no reason
to expect there's a single mechanism of
action right in fact what we have here
is this is a classic for Biological
thinking because consider the the puzzle
that kovat 19 or the virus that's
causing the syndrome is is facing it has
to get into a body which requires it to
invade human cells and then it has to
spread cell to cell but the particular
site that it invades and the cells that
it skips to have a lot to say about the
symptomatology from the point of view of
the patients and the doctors who are
seeing them so you shouldn't expect that
this virus causes one set of symptoms a
lot is contingent on the exact path it
took to get to the place where the
doctor first sees the patient so it is
actually quite likely that different
doctors are seeing different things that
could be the result of genetic variation
between strains of the virus or patients
or patients or different developmental
trajectories of the patients yeah so
this is this is the the lesson of
biology is that the
temptation to to simplify what you're
seeing is obviously important but it's
very easy to take it too far in biology
because complexity is you know is
present in every biological facet yeah
okay so the Corrections that I had we
already covered one about urine it turns
out that eggs do have Salmonella inside
of them because salmonella can actually
is actually sometimes found in some
cases in the ovaries of chickens and so
yes most the salmonella is coming from
the surfaces of eggs and if you wash the
surface of your egg just before you
break it you are much more much less
likely to get Salmonella but it is
sometimes inside of the egg from the
beginning which is news to me to me as
well and then the final one was with
regard to UV light and viral decay you
would raised the question in life
something I'd said earlier about isn't
sunlight a great disinfectant and
something to that effect and I'd say no
actually it seems like it's UVC that's
the best best route to to decaying
viruses and such and it turns out I had
just received a paper that I had not yet
read which called the influence of
simulated sunlight on the inactivation
of influenza virus and aerosol so this
has been influenza virus which is not a
corona virus but it is a virus and and
it's a simulation but what what they
find is indeed that the half-life of
viruses of the influenza virus in a dark
room is something like half an hour
whereas in full intensity against
simulated sunlight it's two point four
minutes two point four minutes is 0.4
minutes compared to a half an hour for
the half-life they're basically that how
long it takes for half of the virus to
decay and become inactive and capable of
being active in full sunlight
well then I'm proud to say that the Dark
Horse podcast is the first place that
you will hear that simulated sunlight is
the best disinfectant yeah so it is
interestingly this will be our topics
today are going to be about death and
also peer review and this is not related
to the death topic but
this article which is in the Journal of
infectious diseases is actually
published in 2020 but it is not it is it
it went through peer review you know
over the last probably a year or two so
it just happens to have been published
and you know in the in the log of
publication to to emerge just as this
this global pandemic is hitting which is
just an accident
most of most everything that we are
hearing from scientific research right
now about the SARS co2 and the disease
it causes co19
pandemic are on preprint servers and
have and are you know just coming out
fast and furious and it's up to us
you know everyone basically to assess
whether or not it's it's true or not all
right we will return to that topic when
we get to the question of peer review
later on yeah all right how would you
like to you have something planned with
respect to how we not exactly I mean I
have some I have some things I want to
say but if you if you wanted to start go
for it yeah how about I do that so today
is a somber day for us that is the
anniversary of the death of Heather's
father seven seven years ago it's hard
to believe it was seven years ago and
Heather will say more about what took
place and what it meant but I will just
say for my part that Heather's father
was an extremely unusual guy his name
was Doug and he and I didn't get along
perfectly at first I think that's kind
of normal with you know father's and
their daughters and their daughters
would be boyfriends and all but
ultimately we came to be quite close and
I must say I still in some sense have
not reckoned my reconciled myself to his
death he is somebody we comment on
frequently we given all that we've been
through in the last few years we've
often wondered what he would make of it
and we really wished we had his
perspective he was a Heather will tell
you more about his his professional
background but he was a computer
scientist who was regarded as a mentor
by many which was interestingly we
discovered that in the sense after he
was gone when people told us what their
relationships with him had been but he
was a man of very few words he was an
excellent teacher but it was not
primarily about him telling you what to
do it was he taught through other ways
and one of them was by by illustrating
so we we miss him a great deal and we
are very much still grappling with with
the loss you know so a tremendous number
of people are dying now in the u.s. from
Kovac 19 and it's possible that there
are slightly fewer deaths from a few
other sources because of the because of
the lockdown but by by unfortunate
happenstance there are two other deaths
that in our world this week and you know
maybe we'll say a few words about at
least one of those at the end of this
but knowing that this was coming that we
were due to do another live stream on
the anniversary of my father's death I
was thinking about it in light of what
it might tell us about what the deaths
from coma 19 are doing to people and how
particularly this disease which of
course my father knew nothing about
having died seven years ago is affecting
people in ways that is hard to quantify
but pretty easy to qualify if you start
to put putting stories together did you
say that the two deaths in our world
were not yeah I do
yeah we so far have have no one that we
know directly you know there's a couple
of second-order you know we know of some
academics and such who have died from
coma nineteen but the two people who we
who died are experienced deaths this
week I had nothing to the Cova 19 so
in 2012 Brett and I were both teaching
evergreen and it was an early spring
morning and for some reason I'd gotten
up very very early and was building
curriculum for the day it was maybe the
first week of Spring Quarter and the
boys were asleep and Brett was asleep
and my phone rang and normally I
wouldn't have been up at six ten or so
it was my mom and she said your dad's
having a heart attack the paramedics are
here I don't know I don't know what to
do
they had my parents had moved to Olympia
the year before year-and-a-half before
to be near us to be near us and their
grandchildren and I ran upstairs to get
changed and Brett woke up and said we're
breaking the kids were taking them I
said now don't know we don't need to and
you said yeah no we need to take them
over there and you drove you drive
faster normal conditions but you drive
as fast as I remember you you driving to
get to my parents house and there were
three emergency vehicles in the driveway
again it's long before dawn at this
point and I said Brett stay in the car
with the boys I'm gonna run in and you
wanted to see what I wanted to see what
the situation was our kids were at that
point almost nine and seven and I just
didn't want them walking in on a scene
that was really gruesome and I went to
the door it was locked which was strange
and I banged on it and my mom opened the
door and there's my dad like that was a
big guy six-two and big I was on the
floor and there were seven eight or nine
first responders there EMTs and firemen
working on him and my mom was standing
there with with the main guy and she
came over to me and said he says your
dad's gone
they've been working on him for 20
minutes and he's had no sign of life and
he's gone and I I started crying or
hugged her and then there's a knock on
the door and it's Brett with the boys
whose
he's come with them and the EMTs we
opened the door and they see these two
children in the doorway and I tell them
your grandfather's died and they start
crying and the first responders keep
working on my father and they bring him
back they bring him back which is just
extraordinary and it points to the
connection that we have between us as
human beings that sometimes is the
difference between life and death now he
had been out he had been without a
heartbeat for at least 20 minutes and I
have no idea how much longer than that
it actually was because it took some
time for them to arrive after my mother
called them and she of course has no
idea how long that actually was but they
then got him to the hospital and and
Western medicine just did wondrous
things for him over the next seven weeks
in the ICU seven weeks in the ICU out of
the ICU a few times but mostly in they
put him into a cold coma they basically
dropped his core temperature to I don't
even remember what it was was like 92
degrees I'm I want to say but I don't
remember I didn't look it up
the idea being based on empirical
results that people who died in people
who almost drown in cold water tend to
have better results cognitively later on
than people who almost drown in warm
water that the slowing down of the
slowing down of all biological and
chemical processes basically stops
damage as well slows damage as well so
they put him into this cold coma
and the amazing cardiologist whom we
spoke with in the hospital that morning
said any outcome is possible you may
never interact with him again and he may
get up and walk away from this and be
fine
and we really can't say at least we
can't make any predictions at all until
we begin to pull him out of the
medically induced cold comment 24 hours
or so he was I wouldn't say just to jump
forward not to tell the entire story
here but I wouldn't say he
was a hundred percent after he came out
of the ICU seven weeks later but he was
really close and he went through bypass
open heart bypass surgery he was on a
heart-lung machine you know this this
kind of medical intervention which is
extraordinary and saved my father's life
a number of times during that spring of
2012 was was remarkable and so I must
say I was never sure whether the little
bit that he didn't seem to come back was
the fact that he was so shaken by what
had happened to him and that you know
you can imagine being in his shoes you
would always every time you forgot
something you would wonder was that some
capacity I lost so he there was a way in
which he was shaken you know I never saw
anything that actually caused me to
think up yeah he's definitely definitely
lost some capacity yeah I I agree I
think mostly you know he was a hobo I
don't know the lingo because I don't
play bridge but he was a extraordinary
bridge player who was still playing in
and I think winning some tournaments in
that year after he had been in the ICU
for seven weeks I what I had some
questions for him about our taxes and I
you know I worked on taxes with ebony
seemed to be the usual his usual intact
self but now fast forward so we all my
mother and and our boys and us got
another year with him and it was such a
gift and it was in part anyway given to
us by not just those amazing EMTs who
continued working on him after they had
said there was no hope but also the
remarkable medical intervention by the
people at the hospital by the doctors at
the hospital at st. Pete's in Olympia
but by the beginning of 2013 all the
same issues that have been plaguing him
before or coming back he had long-term
heart damage he had what is it chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease COPD CP Oh
copd he was overweight he was a drinker
you know he had yet all of these he had
all of these I guess their comorbidities
right and he had always been someone he
grew up on a pig farm in Iowa in
northeastern Iowa he used to call
himself a little country programmer you
know went to Notre Dame then went to
Carnegie Tech before was Carnegie Mellon
and worked for a series of the big
companies in computer science he was
translating he basically he he
translated he spoke both hardware and
software and he worked as the interface
both between those two domain levels and
between the people who often couldn't
speak directly to one another and
through all of that he had you know he
had the farm boy in him and part of that
was we eat from the land when we can and
I Douglas huiying I'm not gonna take
drugs unless I have to but especially in
that year after he had been in the ICU
for so many weeks they just were
stacking drug upon drug upon drug on him
and he didn't want it but they you know
it's hard to say no when you know that
your life is hanging in the balance so
by by early April of 2013 it looked like
he needed another another bypass surgery
another open-heart surgery and he was
scheduled for one for April 12th of 2013
and I was supposed to be getting back
from a field trip that I was leading
with my class then so I said hey Dad can
I borrow your car where I'm taking my
class up to Orcas Island the San Juan
Islands just gorgeous gorgeous spot
can't Maria in a place that we've taken
we've taken a few field trips a few
classes but I'll come home a day early
I've got two amazing former students who
are acting as my TAS and they can wrap
up the field trip on the final day and
I'll get the first ferry out of there on
Friday and come home and be and be in
the hospital with you on the and mom on
the day of surgery but in talking with
my mom on Monday and Tuesday of that
field trip I just had this sense that
things were not going well and so I left
my field trip in steady and capable
hands
of gosh I think it was Dallas and Cory
um and and drove home early Wednesday
drove straight to the hospital
and he was there in his room with my mom
and he and I shared maybe eight minutes
of conversation during which time I told
him I loved him and he told me he loved
me
and reminded me how much he loved the
children our children I just mentioned
you he loved you very much
and then he seized and I never saw him
conscious again but um it was hours
later I had time to call you and to say
bring him now bring bring the boys you
you come and bring the boys now he's
back in the ICU I think this is it and
the five of us my mom his wife and you
and I'm Brett and our two children were
around him as he as he died and were
able to be in the room you know terrible
ICU room for an hour or so afterwards
and then we later I don't know how many
days later accompanied his body to the
crematorium he had been Catholic in sort
of a past life but but he had no
objection to that ending for him and in
his ending I thought this is how no one
wants to die ever
no one wants to die in the hospital
Americans don't know how to die we've
lost track of most of our most of our
ancient rituals every society that has
been looked at every culture that's been
looking at has death rituals and to the
extent that individuals are still from
cultures that do or have created some
for their themselves our our
governmental and medical establishment
has mostly kept us from those rituals
under times of extreme duress and he was
luckier than most because he had five
they let the children into the ICU
because it was the end which normally
they wouldn't have done and so he had
five people around him who loved him
deeply
but people dying of Kovan 19 generally
don't have that at all and that loss of
contact between between humans is so
profound and so extreme and it must be
so
alienating and isolating and lonely it
feels like there must be something that
we can do to make better deaths not just
now in this in this time of global
pandemic but across all deaths yeah it's
really a difficult problem too because
so many deaths now take place in the
hospital and obviously at this moment if
you can avoid being in the hospital it's
exactly the last place you want to be
just from the perspective of catching
this virus so yeah you know obviously it
can't be the same priority level as
figuring out how to treat people and
prevent them from dying but there are
going to be deaths and you know even
deaths from other things under these
circumstances are just so compromised by
the regulations around who can be where
yeah I had it it doesn't need to be
addressed I have a interesting list here
of ways that ways that death is
celebrated just it's from its from the
introduction of this pretty good paper
called not just dead meat an
evolutionary account of corpse treatment
in mortuary rituals across 59 I think it
has cultures from 2017 and it's just
this list alone is worth is worth
considering even a cursory examination
of the anthropological record reveals
the many ways that people treat their
dead prior to disposal corpses are
washed embalmed anointed pickled
dismantled painted adorned up with
jewelry clothed wrapped placed in the
container
moved mutex tensive li touched embraced
wept over shouted at danced over and
force-fed food among other practices I
and that's just that celebrates humanity
right there
that we have come up with so many you
know what for every single one of us
some of those sound crazy yeah and for
someone on earth whatever sounds crazy
to every to the rest of us it feels like
the most natural thing in the world
yeah but everywhere there's something
everywhere there's something everywhere
there's something it's a human Universal
Earth rituals are almost ubiquitous
death rituals seemed to be ubiquitous
yeah and uh our culture has done so much
to turn them generic and to sanitize the
process and to turn it into a commodity
it's it's frightening yeah
alright is there more to say you think
on this topic I think there there may
well be more but maybe we maybe we
stopped caring for now did you want to
say what's up thank you no it's okay
yeah maybe let's go
okay all right so the other topic is a
it's tempting to try to find a
connection between death and peer review
here our view is sometimes the death of
good idea yes it's where good ideas go
to die but in any case I wanted to raise
an issue with respect to peer review
because of what I'm seeing unfold which
is a very very unusual circumstance so
for those of you who are not academics
and have not been academics there's a
part of the world of how science and
other disciplines unfold that you can't
see and you probably can't into it
which is that well there's this
principle called the Matthew principle
which is something to the effect of to
those with much much is given the idea
being a positive feedback loop where
those who have lots of something end up
with more and those who have little end
up with less this is found across our
system there are amplifiers that take
parities and increase them and one of
the places that this happens is in terms
of academic access so at a very
high-powered university you will have
incredible access to what we call the
literature alright your library will
have a great many of those things
available to you and there's ways to
access any that aren't present in your
library and you sort of come to think
this is just the nature of the world
you've now joined a field you have
access to all the things to take place
and it turns out that as soon as you
leave a major university even if you
step to a just somewhat less renowned
place you discover a spectacular
decrease in what you have access to and
if you go to a college you find that
your access plummets and if you leave
academia altogether you find yourself
facing a paywall that's asking you to
pay thirty five bucks to glimpse a paper
that you just need to look at a little
bit to figure out whether some result
makes sense so anyway there's a problem
with peer review that begins with the
fact that it is a gate through which
most people cannot pass hey folks sorry
about that we had some kind of a
momentary power failure that took out
cameras computer everything associated
with the podcast and it took us a moment
to get back I've got a conspiracy
hypothesis oh is that right yeah it was
the editors at Nature what took us out
the editors at nature what took us out I
like that I thought this is and I like
the phrasing of it thank you all right
well here we an apologies I think what
we will do is we will have this second
part to stream also be the super chat
answer stream we will just combine them
okay does that work
sure good all right so let me just
finish up what I was getting at the fact
of the literature being available in
proportion to the prestige of your
University is a hidden fact about about
the way peer-review works but there is
another set of facts that is equal sorry
there are things being done here to
resurrect the stream amazing tactical
support Zachary
yes you had nothing to do with the
failure so far as we can tell tape and
baling wire is creeping around you can
you can come up here if you need to I
think we've got it okay all right so
here's what I want to get it I'll just
cut to the chase so that is it we don't
face another set of problems the Cova
Dean situation is revealing something
it's actually a kind of test of
something that we have been talking
about the dangers of peer review Eric my
brother has been talking about the
dangers of peer review on the portal
podcast his podcast and the the long and
short of it is this peer review sounds
like something that you need to have
because of course work that doesn't
withstand the review of peers isn't very
high quality but that does not mean that
peers need to have veto power on whether
your work ever sees the light of day
because your peers of course may have a
conflict of interest about whether or
not they want your work to see the light
of day or they may be so myopic that
they can't see the wisdom in what you're
saying and therefore they will block it
because I say it's low quality when
really what it is is very far ahead of
its time or you and a few of your
dearest friends have formed a cabal and
you effectively peer-review each other
into lots of publications without saying
anything about the quality of the work
that is very frequent so why are we
raising this now we're raising it
because the Cova Dean situation is
producing an alternative view of an
alternative way of doing science which
is to say because kovat 19 is unfolding
in real time and because it is very
important that we figure out how it
works how it's infecting people what
it's vulnerable --'tis we maybe how it
is that we can behave so that we don't
catch it all of these things this is
unfolding outside of peer review there's
no time for the journals to send these
papers out and have peers review the
work and decide whether or not it could
be published there's no time to publish
it on paper
so it's unfolding on these preprint
servers and what that means is that
people are putting up papers they're
accessible to anybody with an internet
connection
they vary a tremendous amount or not I
don't think any of the preprint servers
are behind a paywall right yeah and so
you know the preprint servers weren't
really designed for this purpose the
preprint servers were designed in effect
so that anybody could lodge an idea
irrespective of where they were in peer
review and later on you could see it so
immediate access was important and and
such things but very often they actually
are limited in terms of who can use them
in other words you have to be sort of a
member in good standing within a field
or something like this but that's all
neither here nor there the important
point is that these papers are emerging
in real time every day there are new
papers available that discussed the
mechanisms at work with the virus the
symptomatology of the patients the
epidemiology all of these things they
are accessible to anyone most of us do
not know who these authors are so these
things are now being broadcast to
something much larger than a field
they're being broadcast to anybody who
has a scientific interest in
understanding how this thing works and
it is effectively the proof that this
does function that the fact of no
quality control on these things is not
creating a hazard it's creating an
opportunity that we can now you the
public if you want to can tune in to the
dialog between you know let's say
doctors who are seeing symptoms that are
somewhat inconsistent with each other
you can tune in as the viral adjusts are
discussing the similarities of the
receptor molecules in one virus versus
another and the fact that this works is
tremendously important and what I very
much hope is that at the end of the Cova
dean situation that we do not simply
decide that peer review has to be
re-established as the only way to
maintain quality what I hope is that we
will recognize that we've discovered
that in fact peer review is
the abomination many of us think it is
and that it should be replaced by some
sort of open-source alternative yeah so
there's a route there's a related Thank
You Zack
there's a related issue I'm not actually
sure might be interesting to figure out
to here with you live how exactly you
think at enter place but there's a
related issue that you alluded to with
regard to our one universities you're
the big research universities with with
a lot of funding have the gold standard
in terms of journal access and if you're
a faculty or a student at one of those
universities it's invisible to you once
you know how to use the system it just
it just slides right through and you
know in fact this paper that I mentioned
at the beginning of the first live
stream the influence of simulated
sunlight on the inactivation of
influenza virus and era cells that came
to us through Princeton you know it's
it's so easy we haven't we now for right
now have this this our one university
level access and all you have to do is
ask you have to you have to be able to
find it but then but then you just a
scan it and it shows up for you so
there's there's a maintaining of the
status quo by virtue of the fact that if
you're at one of these places you have
access to the literature and if you're
not at one of these places you don't
have access you don't know what you're
missing and it's very hard to jump into
even knowing what it is that you're
missing and therefore what to ask for
so when we were at Evergreen which is
you know a public liberal arts college
and was was once capable of doing very
high quality work at the both the
faculty and the student level one of my
soap boxes the entire time that we were
there was trying to get access to mostly
news web of science which is you know
the science Citation Index which is this
indexing database that indexes so many
journals you know across a wide array of
field is mostly Natural Sciences actual
and physical sciences but and it's not a
full-text database you can't from there
get to get to all of the full-text but
by learning how to use its search
function well you really confine you can
do the lit review you can do the
getting the lit review that everyone
needs to be able to do but it's very
expensive and evergreen was never rich
and early in our tenure there I was able
to convince the then library Dean to to
buy it for the school and I taught my
students at every single quarter and so
you know this is this is the access that
you need and then it got cut a few years
before we left half years before we did
get cut and the argument made to me you
know obviously ultimately was a
financial argument it was expensive but
the argument made to me by some of the
people within library administration
there was basically as a researcher as a
scholar as a faculty member there are
only a couple of journals that you are
probably interested in looking at anyway
what the hell do you need all this
really broad access for and this to me
is just an encapsulation of one of the
things that is most wrong with with
higher ed now and not not just the
educational end of it but the research
and the idea that most people are doing
research by being really really familiar
with a couple of journals and maybe they
also get the tables of contents for
Nature and Science and one or two other
pretty big journals in in their inboxes
if they're scientists but otherwise they
just read a couple and they don't need
to look through to draw on anything
outside of the very narrow field well of
course we have a crisis in science and
in replication and a hypothesis testing
and in you know and in peer review and
everything of course we do because we're
training a bunch of people to do brick
in the wall science instead of big
potentially paradigm shifting hypothesis
driven science we are forcing
specialization at an absurd level
exactly which is not only terrible for
academics but absolutely awful for
students it's terrible um you you should
not be teaching your students to
specialize at this level undergraduates
need to understand how they need to
understand the general underlying stuff
before there's any argument for
specialization and so for them not to
have broad access across the literature
is just catastrophic and it's it's
frankly criminal it doesn't look like an
education if you're going to be relying
in the literature at all if you're going
to expect students to learn literature
review skills and maybe that's just not
your thing at all like you know it
didn't tend to be your thing right but
if you like I also want students to be
able to really review the literature
they have to be able to review it
broadly they have to be able to assess
the claims and you know across a number
of domains knowing that they will be
expert to begin with in none of them and
they will never be expert in all of them
but that they can they they go in and
they read it and they read it again and
at first everyone's thought is almost
everyone's thought is I can't understand
this I must be too dumb to understand it
I must not have the level of education
required to understand it and after a
while the best students begin to sense
you know what maybe this is written in a
way such that I am not meant to
understand it there there are these
barriers to entry put up at every single
step to keep basically the riffraff oh
well there are two things you have terms
of art which are necessary in order to
do the high quality work and then you
have jargon which masquerade is terms of
art that are basically there just to
keep people who aren't inside the club
from knowing what's being said well
that's an important distinction yeah I
think it is yeah okay so on to your
super chat questions there we go oh wait
you were gonna tell a story oh the story
was the following your father my father
who art in heaven maybe somewhere right
he's not here
your father the computer engineer
programmer extraordinaire had a picture
of himself sitting at a terminal
debugging software with a toilet plunger
on the monitor I have that in the in the
WordPress site that I created for him
after he died I have that picture it's
it's an excellent it's a marvel and a
cure yes and it it sort of reflected his
his approach to things like debugging he
was definitely a no-nonsense yeah get it
unplugged kind of guy that's right
alright alright first Super chats
spot-on Thank You Nate says a question
about models specifically pertaining to
non regular non repeating events are
they predictive or do they serve a
different purpose
if predictive how do they derive an
ought the future from an is a present
it's just an inductive versus deductive
question is that what he's after
maybe maybe so I mean there they claim
they're predictive of course but is it
is it inductive versity doctor I'm not
sure here's what I wish I knew which of
these mics was picking us up yeah I'm
not sure I'm not sure what the question
means but I have the sense that this is
this is the answer you're looking for
unfortunately models are being abused
they are taken to be reflective of the
things that are being modeled and in a
complex system it's very hard to get the
model right enough and it is very easy
to fool yourself into thinking that you
have the model right enough so what I
would argue is that the philosophy of
science logically applied to models
suggest that models can be valid places
to generate hypotheses which then need
to be tested against nature they are not
valid tests of hypotheses I can't say no
model ever has been you had obviously in
a very simple scenario build a model in
which you can test the hypothesis but in
a complex system they are valid ways to
generate hypotheses you may be able to
observe something in a model that you
didn't expect but you can't test things
there and that's I think what we're
doing wrong good fellow biologist and
academic here
what is your take on dr. David
Sinclair's information theory of aging
as well as his and Aubrey de Grey
approach to combat senescence and aging
love you guys
wonderful Johan I sure hope the audio is
on for this ok out of the
okay great all right David Sinclair's
informational theory of aging I believe
now I'm not thoroughly versed in David
Sinclair's probably it's a hypothesis
and not a theory what I would say is
that in my paper on telomeres I advanced
what I believe to be the same hypothesis
I made an error which is that I used a
term which I now know would have been
better replaced with another term I said
histological entropy which many people
took to be an analogue for normal
entropy what I should have said was
epigenetic entropy so what do you I mean
I I loved that phrase histological
entropy as you know but what do you mean
by it for those what I'm what I mean by
it is if you look at the way development
unfolds cells know what to do that is to
say they know which of their genes to
transcribe based on two kinds of
information based on a history of what
cells they came from that is to say
their lineage and information from
things like neighbors that says where
they are as you get old they lose track
of these kinds of information because a
they are no longer the next cell in the
logical sequence from development what
they many of them are is cells ourselves
that have stepped in to replace a cell
that was lost due to damage or wearing
out and so the amount of information
about where a cell is is reduced based
on basically in increasingly bad
information and that bad information
compounds because of the sent to the
extent that one cell is confused it's
putting out a confusing message to all
of its neighbors and so what you get is
informational breakdown of the natural
order in cells which perfectly reflects
what you see under microscope which is
from a young animal tissues are very
well organized and the older the animal
is the more chaotic they become and at
the just at the gross phenotype level an
example and I think will will fit for
people is you know as you age hair start
showing up and play
is that it doesn't normally show up yep
right and not just you know during
puberty you get secondary sex
characteristics and hair grows and your
pets and your growing and such but you
get you know the the stereotype of the
old man with the crazy eyebrows and the
hair gonna have his ears I resent that
this is I think a realization of this
histological entropy yep now that was my
original example was a hair follicle out
of place and I've heard David Sinclair
the reason I believe these suggesting is
clear your paper predates Sinclair's or
it comes after well it's possible that
he wrote something much earlier but I
don't think so I think mine is far
earlier and that I wish I had called it
epigenetic entropy I think it would have
been much clearer histological entropy
is I think a very valid term but it it
did lead some people to misunderstand
what was being said and what about
degree what about what about Aubrey de
Grey Aubrey de Grey is perspective I'm
basically just repeating what he has
said is that the failure of the human
body due to senescence is effectively an
engineering problem and that if it is
addressed as an engineering problem it
has a small number of causes and then if
we address those causes one by one lo
and behold we will defeat aging and I
agree with him that if you do to feed
aging that living a thousand years
becomes readily within shooting distance
where we disagree is that the fact that
it may technically be an engineering
problem has anything to say about how
tractable it is and in fact years ago
technology review out of MIT ran a
contest for any academic who could show
that de Grey was not worth taking
seriously and I did not yet have my PhD
I don't think I was taken very seriously
by the judges but my point oh I did
submit one and my point was okay so
aging is an engineering problem
here's another engineering problem
taking a 1965 Ford Mustang and allowing
it to trans people transport people to
the moon without ever taking it out of
service right in other words having a
functional vehicle
every step along the way as you convert
that Ford Mustang into you know an
Apollo 11 or something like that and the
point is yeah that's an engineering
problem it's just not tractable yeah so
my basic opinion is that barber degre
has led us to a kind of false optimism
about how tractable this problem is I
also in my response to him took him to
task for having essentially no plan for
addressing the informational breakdown
of the mind that even if you were to
solve all of the cellular aging and
tissue aging problems of the body you
have another kind of problem which is
that the brain is not designed to
function for a thousand years so you
know how much do you remember as a young
person if you're planning to live a
thousand years you may be so forgetful
as a young person that it's not worth it
that's right the algorithms that work
for memory for an 80 200 year old
lifespan will be very very different
yeah if the primary treatment is
ventilators which are 20% effective why
do models show massive deaths in an
overrun medical system shouldn't the
increase be 20% at most can simpler care
be performed at home can you do that one
more time yeah I think I think that
there's I think that there's a couple
logical leaps here that don't quite
track if the primary treatment is
ventilators parentheses 20% effective
why do models show massive deaths in an
overrun medical system shouldn't the
increase be 20% at most consumer care be
performed at home ah yeah you get it I
feel like maybe there's just some words
maybe it's not logical leaps but I'm not
quite tracking what the question is I
mean the primary treatment seems to be
ventilators which is we talked about
last time may not be the right the right
tool to be using I don't know where
there's 20 percent effective numbers
coming from I've heard you know in some
countries once you put on a ventilator
it seems like you got a 50/50 chance
I've not heard 80% of people who go on
ventilators end up dying so I don't know
what the measure of efficacy here would
be and then you know ventilators versus
overrun you have something more here I
don't really I think I think at some
level the question comes down to if the
failure of the system because it's over
loaded is the cause of death then we
should be able to estimate the degree to
which we have a higher residual than
expected based on how many ventilators
we can't find for people mm-hmm but I
don't quite get how maybe I'm just
misunderstanding yes/no and I guess
there's another interpretation there
that if if the tool that you get in a
hospital if the major treatment is a
ventilator and it's not very effective
and you're of course more at risk in a
hospital of getting other having other
problems maybe there's a point at which
even if you're really really sick the
best move is to be at home rather than
in a hospital yeah it may be the
question and I think you know there is
there is something to be investigated
there I'm gonna just ask you to look at
the chat sack and every couple of
minutes we're gonna check in and say can
you hear us okay because I have no sense
of all right great please tell us about
the handsome Selectric - so I didn't no
idea what you can see but I know
generally I block it somebody can see
well enough and knows enough to know
that that must be a Selectric - which
indeed it is yeah it has a little story
that goes along with it you and I both
as kids grew up in a house that happened
to have two houses even it to separate
houses because otherwise that'd be gross
but two separate houses that had a
Selectric typewriter and I remember
thinking this was a very I was a very
mechanically inclined kid and this was a
super interesting device you never took
apart your childhood home Selectric oh
boy
my parents learned quickly that I had a
tendency to take things apart and as I
recall it I was more or less forbidden
to touch this electric - because it
a very fancy typewriter and although I
was good at putting things back together
I was expected not to be able to do it
maybe it can i interject here and point
out that you taught our younger son
yesterday how to take apart a carburetor
yes so so you're still at it and you
rebuilt it yeah but actually this device
here so we both grew up in homes that
had a selector typewriter and I wanted I
wanted my kids to have a Selectric
typewriter that we could turn into a
printer by basically triggering the
switches in the keys basically I wanted
to hack into the typewriter and then
trigger the individual letters to type
by triggering the switches associated
with each key and we happen to cross
this typewriter which looked to be in
great shape I plugged it in at Goodwill
didn't really work it came on but it did
not work and it was 11 bucks and I
thought 11 bucks all by it I bet you I
can fix that bad boy and got it home and
opened it up and discovered a wow is
that thing wild on the inside and be
there ain't no switches in fact there
are only two electric parts in the
entire thing and they literally are the
motor and the switch everything else in
there is mechanical and run the motor is
basically sending power through a belt
into this whole system and everything
else that happens in there is mechanical
so so you could technically power that
with a bicycle you could totally power
that with a bicycle and I probably
should just to spite those people who
were dubious of my my plan with the
compressed air don't you also discover
that they're like two or three Selectric
repairmen left in the country oh it's
more than that it's a small number and
there'd win I mean those things has got
to be one of the most complex it's not
really a consumer object it was a
business object but one of the most
complex commodities ever devised the
thing is amazing and they were they were
repairmen whose job was to travel around
and service those things in place on a
regular schedule but that was the what
late 70s varieties point as most of
those people are now dead they're a
small number of them still out there
some of some of them are referring these
things you know and selling you could
buy them for like I did 11 bucks and
then you refer bit and you sell it for a
few hundred or something but anyway it's
a fantastically complicated object and I
sort of at the point I realized how
complex it was I started figuring out
how to fix it and I'm still learning
it's it's very difficult but anyway I've
got that one up and running it works the
correction works it can actually lift
letters off the page so anyway that's
the story excellent in light of the
disappearance of dr. I fen by probably
mispronouncing the name in light of the
disappearance of dr. i fen who leaked
the first report on the kovat virus
would it be advisable to protect future
whistleblowers with something akin to
diplomatic immunity
I think whistleblowers deserve
diplomatic immunity some kind of
immunity it's hard to know in advance
you know how do you how do you know that
you are worthy of immunity before you
get disappeared well I would say if and
only if you want an honorable system
figure out how to protect whistleblowers
under SM and they a lot of people give
lip service to the idea of protecting
whistleblowers but it is absolutely
essential and I say that I feel like I
feel like a whistleblower when it comes
to MOUs telomeres and you know it's like
forking it's the wrong metaphor it I
tried to sound the alarm and the Bell
wouldn't ring the whistle wouldn't blow
whatever it was it just didn't work yeah
hypoxia hypothesis current and former
smokers are showing up underrepresented
in the ICU data would this suggest
evidence for the hypothesis now I feel
like I saw something and I don't have it
in front of me and this isn't my
computer this is yours I can't look at I
thought I saw the opposite I thought I
saw that smoking was one of the risk
factors one of the top six risk factors
I just saw a list today where diabetes
was the top risk factor kidney disease
was in there
COPD was in there I thought smoking was
so I don't
we can still take this on but I would I
would put a strong one caveat on I'm not
sure that the claim is right I parked
with regard to the hypoxia hypothesis
current and former smokers are showing
up underrepresented in the ICU data
that's the claim here would this suggest
evidence for the hypoxia hypothesis it
almost feels to me like it should go the
other way why would they be
underrepresented in the ICU data is that
suggesting that they are healthier
because they've already faced a low
oxygen like they're effectively
acclimated yeah I don't quite see the
connection so if you want a question
like that address spell out a little bit
more what you think the connection might
be and also let us know where we can
find the evidence that you're going on
the connection is there I don't know if
there are character limits on the super
chat but definitely a link to a
reference would help here I tweeted
y'all an account of a woman with strange
symptoms who tested positive for kovat
I'll resend if needed wondering your
thoughts
I don't remember of offhand which one
this which this was strange symptoms who
tested positive for mm-hmm code so yeah
made do resend do resend I don't
remember offhand what what this is I
don't either but I will just say that is
certain to be a pattern because so many
people who are infected with this virus
are asymptomatic and so many people have
symptoms for which no known cause exists
that surely you're gonna end up testing
some people finding out they're positive
and you don't want to just contribute in
perhaps sometimes they have that are
unrelated you to cope at 19 absolutely
yep Hawaii H I Hawaii has implemented a
curfew Michigan is preventing the sale
of non-essential items when is it too
far how do we respond once we determine
it is yeah this is a really I'm
wondering this very much lately you know
that the the part the node here that I'm
tracking most acutely is preventing
people from going into nature
and this Miss read this like very not
just authoritarian but didactic like we
said stay at home we said
shelter-in-place yeah that means you
don't what was that there's a report out
of Southern California I think and
Sanitas actually where we've got some
friends who were in there people were in
their cars watching the sunset alone in
their cars are in their cars with the
people whom they were already quarantine
and with watching the sunset and they
can receive either a thousand dollar
fine or six up to six months in jail for
not sheltering in place they're in their
cars watching the sunset yep this is an
incredible either just blatant abuse of
power or more likely a confused
interpretation of a far too broad
directive so I would add I don't believe
you can make a society functional
without discretion and so in some sense
what we are seeing is a failure to
either provide discretion or to utilize
it properly what you need is people who
understand what the objective of the
policy is and know how to make
exceptions that don't violate the spirit
of the policy and so to the extent I I
don't remember where I encountered it
might even be a friend got evicted from
a public park they were sitting on a
bench alone you know fifty feet from the
nearest person and they were apparently
told that they were in violation of the
law and the fact is you know we use the
analogy sometimes that we are physically
a robot but that robot has a computer
riding on its shoulder and that computer
is it has needs and so if we simply
start figuring out what the robot needs
to do in order not to catch this virus
and we stop paying attention to the fact
that you're going to drive people stark
raving mad if you lock them down and
don't let them access those things that
would make them feel some degree of
normalcy and have almost no risk of
catching or transmitting the disease and
give them no sense of legitimate hope or
this thing
ever ending yeah then you know you we're
gonna create a catastrophe and also next
time this happens we in the northern
hemisphere might be heading into winter
not summer right we are in some sense
lucky that even if the virus doesn't
respond to warmer weather the fact that
people you know many of them might have
a courtyard they can go sit in or a tree
they can sit under that's very helpful
but we need to figure out how to do this
humanely and that means you know the
question is apt when is it too much no
it's it's it's quite apt it seems like
it is too much and but but part of how
it's too much is the rote and robot like
receiving and dispensing of orders so
I'm reminded of you know we're not we're
not going through these as quickly as I
was hoping we would before but um I
wonder if you would talk a little bit
about this at first it's gonna sound
like it's coming at it out of nowhere
but your experience during occupy when
you insisted on engaging with the
policemen who showed up to disband the
Occupy artisan call it yeah the
participants who were who were at the
capital campus in Olympia Washington
and you know there were a number of our
students who were up there with us and
then I think on a couple of occasions
the police showed up and so I I left
with our children because it was
important that if people were going to
be arrested no one you know it didn't
happen to both but you talked to the
police
yeah I thought it was very important
that the police understand that they
were facing human beings and you know
there were some there were some bad cops
I remember them there were some people
who were clearly interested in
exercising power and but there were also
compassionate people and most of what
you interacted with yes and the thing is
the many of the people who were
associated with Occupy had a strong
anarchist bent I'm quite anti anarchist
but the anarchists have this
that all cops are bastards and all of
this stuff and what that resulted in was
not engaging the cops as if they were
him and treating them as if they are not
human which resulted in the cops feeling
like they were dealing with nonhumans on
the other side and it was a you know it
was just a catastrophe waiting to happen
so I thought you were being a patsy for
wanting to engage right so the idea you
know some some of the the anti-occupy
people would say you're being ridiculous
for engaging with the Occupy people at
all and the people with an Occupy were
saying how not only how foolish of you
but how dare you interact with the cops
and you know you had good human
interactions with the policeman who had
been who had been sent to disband a
group and with whom you had human
interactions yep and I'm waiting for
those stories here yeah now and I don't
I don't see them yet there is so much
contradictory information being given to
us wear a mask masks won't make any
difference stay home go out and get Sun
et cetera how do we sift through it will
prevent the spread of Sina of cover 19
well part of why we're doing what we're
doing is so that you will hear how
people who have a background in biology
and have a lot of experience you know
teaching students are parsing these
questions themselves and you know that
if you optimize for zero likelihood of
spread you will end up in a completely
paralyzed universe right in fact you'll
starve because you won't be able to go
out and get food and at some point your
supplies will dwindle and you'll be
psychologically destroyed you'll be
psychologically destroyed along the way
so in essence what I really I hesitate
to say this because I don't want
somebody to get sick because somebody
else makes a bad call but in essence
what you need is to understand as much
as possible about how the virus
functions both in terms of how it
invades a person how it spreads from
person to person and how it spreads
across a population and then you need to
figure out how to compile a package of
response
is that reduces the likelihood of
transmission as much as possible and you
know to those of you who say no that's
not good enough it's got to be zero look
every time Amazon
delivers you something it's a trade-off
you didn't go out to get it that's good
on the other hand it could come through
your door on the package and so knowing
that it could come through the door on
the package means you can minimize that
chance by dealing with the packages if
it's not safe but basically what you
need is a model models not going to be
perfect but you need a good enough model
that you can then extrapolate and make
decisions that are safe enough and it
will never be perfect because the
information what we believe to be true
now not all of that is going to end up
being true yeah
and this this will always be this will
always be a more true statement with
something that is evolving as rapidly as
not just this virus but specifically our
relationship with it Brett I don't
understand I can't see the rest of this
question Brett I don't understand how
traditional evolution small random
mutations can explain the Cambrian
explosion is it related the Explorer
mode you previously talked about please
explain in such a way that a software
developer understands it yeah so I've
taken a lot of flack from some fairly
prominent people over Explorer modes
which I find funny I can't say what the
particulars are but my basic point is I
don't believe that random mutation on
its own results in the kind of diversity
that we have I believe random mutation
and selection built an earlier world in
which selection then figured out how to
explore more efficiently and that
exploring more efficiently is still a
Darwinian process it's just not so
haphazard and so when we see something
like the Cambrian explosion we may not
know what innovation it was that set
loose this tremendous diversity but the
question is look random mutation might
not get you there but the random
mutation building a mechanism you know
it's like
we got three things all working together
and sort of leapfrogging over one
another but not necessarily in a
particular order I mean there's there's
of course more the magnificence of
microevolution include other things but
the three things you just mentioned a
random mutation selection and
exploration an exploration doesn't does
not show up in the usual list of
mechanisms of microevolution YES on gene
flow it's not drift
we've overly fallen in love with the
random part of the story when it was
never the important part of the story
but you know I would say the question is
a little bit analogous to a you know a
colony of cells how does it navigate
around the room right are you telling me
that colony of cells you know well I'm a
colony of cells how did I know where the
glass of water was well it happens that
some of those cells are organized into a
pattern that allows me to detect the
precise location of the glass and you
know is it amazing
you better believe it's amazing but is
it inexplicable foul it's totally
explicable so so anyway it's that kind
of thing yes selection has figured out a
bunch of tricks to make its exploration
of design space more efficient hello
Brett and Heather I'm a current masters
of Public Health Canada and kovat 19 has
now overtaken as it should our daily
discussions in class stay safe and
healthy thank you as the global supply
chain responds we'll likely see 3d
printers decrease the cost of acquiring
guns disrupting societies that don't
have pervasive gun ownership might the
Second Amendment be a memetic exaptation
of a sort that's the steel man podcasts
questions I thought I understood the
question till the acceptation excess so
exaptation are things that happened for
one reason and our evolutionarily
co-opted for something else which is the
Goldy anism to distinguish between
adaptation and exaptation yes and
probably every adaptation that we can
name could technically be argued to be a
stack of acceptations or something but
so the question is about gun ownership
and the fact that 3d printers will make
decrease the cost of
guns potentially I think that that is
possible now although societies that
don't have pervasive gun ownership but
that do have the materials and Printers
to be printing 3d printing guns at home
what is that going to be Europe mostly
don't know I mean it's it there's a lot
of there's a lot of ifs yep here and
neither you know I can make total sense
of memetic exaptation yeah I mean I I
get what the words would mean together I
don't get how they apply here yeah I
will say for better or worse 3d printers
make the question of how to make a gun
relatively trivial on the other hand you
know the same thing is true for a metal
lathe and a mill right and we can't very
well limit people's access to the stuff
it's tougher though you need you need
more know-how with a metal lathe an a
mill to construct a firearm don't you
yeah because well let's put it this way
you know the blueprints the recipes
whatever you call them exist you know
you get you get the 3d printer you get
the recipe you get the materials yeah
you don't really need to remodel
together anything to tell your 3d
printer to do it on the other hand you
need to know somewhat more to get a CNC
machine to make the parts but it however
you get there we're headed to the same
place which is a gun just isn't that
complicated and so how much no how do
you need to make one not nearly as much
as you'd think it's you know it's just a
question of really whether you're as
long as they're cheap it doesn't happen
that often if they become illegal I
imagine it will happen more yep
Chomsky claims 99% of language uses
internal hence its characteristic use
indicates that its primary function is
for thought and not to facilitate
communication do biologists generally
accept this view I don't I don't I don't
know what biologists generally think but
yeah I don't you don't I'd say I'd say
the opposite is true what is that it is
I believe clear that language has
evolved for cumin
Kayson individuals but once you
communicate between individuals
efficiently with the language it becomes
a very useful shorthand internal to the
mind yeah stay tuned because we will
cover the question of consciousness and
it is wrapped up in this very set of
issues yep no in the whole the
penultimate chapter in her book on the
distinctions between culture and
consciousness yeah where was I does
nature act as a system or individual
organism simply looking out for
themselves
in other words are viruses or diseases a
response of the system to the
overpopulation of a certain species
nature does not act as a system in that
way there is no if the Gaia hypothesis
is not right there is no no forests
don't evolve in the same way that
individual trees and tree species do yep
yes yeah amazing things are possible
mutualism is real and there's no upper
limit to how many creatures could
participate in one but there is a
practical limit on how far that goes so
I would say emergent phenomena are real
it is not right to say that forests
don't exist
but it is right to say that they do not
evolve right they do not have the
prerequisites to evolve so really what
you have is a virus taking advantage of
the kind of closeness that occurs at
high population density it's not that it
is a integral participant in some
agreement to thin the population or
something like that it succeeds more it
conditions for which it does the most
harm yeah at the moment but that it's
not it being sent to do the most harm
how does sickle cell and gene variants
possibly relate to the reasons why this
disease affects African American
communities the most well it would seem
to me that it's relatively simple to
test whether or not the disproportionate
effect in African American communities
is sickle cell related in other words if
we control for those people who
carry the sickle-cell trait into
adulthood do we still see
disproportionate effects my guess is you
would it's not clear to me from this
question if he is referring to our
conversation last time or if this is
coming to novo yeah but it's you know
it's certainly possible and would be
relatively easy yeah to test but let's
just say it is possible that sickle cell
which reduces the capacity of the blood
to carry oxygen puts people who carry
the trait as a heterozygote that is to
say they have one copy of the sickle
cell gene and one copy of the normal
gene it would put them at
disproportionate risk which might result
in more extreme cases it is also
possible that economic factors or
demographic factors are the reason for
the connection and it has nothing to do
with sickle cell this does raise another
correction of sorts in talking about
sickle cell anemia last time I had
suggested that if you're heterozygous
you seem to do fine but you probably
aren't going to be an elite athlete and
a few people pointed out is that David
Goggins I think who is maybe a former
Marine and an elite athlete and is also
heterozygous for sickle cells really
there will be you know there will be
exceptions but that's extraordinary that
is extraordinary yeah I hope I've gotten
the name right I wasn't aware of him
before this let's entertain let's
entertain the conspiracy of covered
being caused by 5g if in fact your
theory is correct could 5g possibly
interfere with hemoglobin because the
iron is some kind of cellular antenna
take this one yeah you're gonna let me
take that one well thank you I would say
I am NOT a fan of the idea of 5g for so
many different reasons I don't think we
need it and I don't think doing
high-energy stuff in such a close
proximity to people is a good idea I
have no idea I've I've heard these
connections to I haven't yet seen
anything that compels me it's worth
going down that road I'm open to the
possibility that there's some evidence
that I need to see but anyway yes it is
unprecedented in
many ways or it's not 5g 5g is
unprecedented and so could it have
effects that we have yet to discover of
course yeah and you know we've got to
unprecedented things coming together at
more or less the same time so of course
they've been put together causally but I
want to see the I want to see the
evidence that makes it worth my time to
chase this particular connection yep
many species go extinct due to
rainforest destruction for animal
agriculture isn't it smarter to let pigs
cows and chicken go extinct to save more
species you let me do that sure okay
first of all farming where tropical
rainforest once stood is never a good
idea it doesn't work very effectively
because the very nature of tropical
rainforest is that they sit on top of
soils which some will claim are
paradoxically depleted I don't think
it's paradoxical at all this is one of
the things I addressed in my
dissertation but the fact is there are
places that you can raise animals and do
it properly I am no fan of factory
farming I think it's despicable and it
cannot be morally justified but that
does not require us the not growing
animals on fragile thin tropical soils
and not growing animals in an inhumane
way on a feedlot or at a high density in
a cage or whatever that does not force
us to go all the way to driving them
extinct we could eat a lot less meat and
not eat zero that would address many of
the health problems that arise when
people go to zero with respect to meat
and it can be done in a way that doesn't
involve a moral compromise so yeah I
don't want to see rainforests cleared to
to raise these animals but it's never
been a good idea in the first place
let's just put a tiny bit more nuance on
that - and say it's not all tropical
soils that are poor right
you know the tropics being that part of
the earth between 23.5 degrees north and
23.5 degrees south it's this huge swath
of the earth it's specifically the
lowland
if she previously alluvial soils that
are hi clay that tend to now have rain
forests on them or those rain forests
have recently which to say sort of since
the Industrial Revolution but in cut but
there are plenty of areas in the tropics
that have rich soils you know anything
that's volcanic in the entire Andes and
and the Cordillera through Central
America for instance have higher quality
soils that can withstand both plant
farming and animal agriculture without
destroying the soils inherently okay
okay regarding your concept of
metaphorical truth why use the word
truth when useful or advantageous would
do
why create different kinds of truth well
the I think the long and short of it is
lots of people seem to have preferences
for how we describe things so that we
don't tread on their particular sacred
belief and I do think that while what I
call metaphorical truth is not true in
the same way that scientific truth
literal truth laboratory truth is true
that when something is true enough to be
the difference between life and death
that it is it is actually unfair not to
use the word so my go-to example would
be the Moken people of the Andaman Sea
who survived the tsunami the Boxing Day
tsunami as a result of a myth told
around the campfire about something
called the LaVon that seeks to taste
human flesh and anyway it was a perfect
warning for the tsunami and my point is
as far as we know no Moken people died
from the tsunami right that's an
incredible track record given how
closely associated with the exact
epicenter of this of the earthquake that
caused the tsunami that they were so
this myth was so good that it saved
hundreds maybe thousands of Moken lives
who are we to say it's not true in some
sense I'm not claiming it's literally
true but it is true enough to save lives
and it's paired right it's it's this
it's this forward phrase that is it is
two terms in literally false
metaphorically true and it it allows
people to go into myth and say okay no
one outside of the Moke and people
believe in the lafoon it's laboum and
yet you can objectively observe the
survival rates of the boken compared
with other people the same distance from
the epicenter of the Boxing Day tsunami
and say well something in that belief
was so effective that it saved all of
their lives is the story of the
particular God that got angry true those
of us of the scientific sort of post
enlightenment worldview would say no but
it created such the right behavior that
is literally false metaphorically true
it's the pairing that is important I
agree it's the pairing I know we need to
move on but I want to say one other
thing which is I am fond of the idea
that for most of us leveling up tends to
come in the form of a vindication that
is tied to a bitter pill and my feeling
about the pairing as you put it between
literally false and metaphorically true
is that if you find yourself on one side
of this divide or the other it's those
two things you get a vindication and a
bitter pill right metaphorically true is
a vindication for people who have these
metaphorical beliefs and want them
treated respectfully but it comes right
after the phrase where they're told now
that's literally false literally false
metaphorically true and until you deal
with the package you're you're taking
license that you're not entitled to
because both things are true keep up the
good work thank you thank you he's come
to Pittsburgh and have coffee with me
I'd love to sit down with you both I
hear the Pittsburgh is gorgeous so I get
to Pittsburgh
my father was in grad school Pittsburgh
many many years ago yep Pittsburgh is
now not a place we can go because there
are people there and social distancing
requires the
yo Matthew principal blues love the
discourse love from Scotland look here
Brett please discuss the potential
connective strand of meaning between
your latent programming versus jordan
Peterson's Union shadow that was like
poetic word salad yeah well yeah I can't
very and it got they got less yeah what
are the two things that you're you're
late into programming yeah that's not a
phrase exactly that you use I don't
think he's talking about mine I think
he's talking about our Layton
programming right discuss the potential
connective strand of meaning between
your latent programming versus JPS
Jungian shadow yeah I mean it seems to
me obvious that your latent programming
would contain all sorts of things
relevant to many phenomena many
historical circumstances and that the
Jungian shadow is Jung's attempt to
systematize these things where it's part
of his attempt so it seems to me like
the connection is rather dependent on
whether Jung had that right I see no
reason the programming at some level
yeah but anyway I don't see anything
doesn't doesn't bother me that the two
would be connected all right stream is
frozen yes
okay keep up the great work would you
talk about Jeffrey Epstein Steam did I
say that right yeah and the new episode
from Eric's podcast
I think Eric put something new up today
he did yeah I think episode 25 don't
know about it yep would you talk about
Jeffrey Epstein I don't have anything to
say about Jeffery um well I I have said
previously that the Jeffrey Epstein
story did not kill itself
I felt very clever when I came up with
that apparently I still do yes
yeah I don't know exactly what to say it
does seem like there are an awful lot of
questions that would reasonably be
answered and as Eric routinely points
out the failure of journalism to be
pursuing questions that seem to be on a
great many Minds is conspicuous if
nothing else
so anyway yes there are lots of
questions and the strata to which
Epstein was connected does raise all
sorts of possibilities so the depth and
the breadth of his connections yeah and
the nature of them yes please can you
discuss invasive species is this a real
thing is there debate here aren't
conservationists simply picking a point
in time and saying we like this best
let's keep it this way Thanks
oh my god it's so much here so this this
is many many hours of conversation
let me try first just I'm gonna go
backwards through the questions aren't
conservationists simply picking a point
in time and saying we like this best
let's keep it this way there is some of
that for sure right there is sort of a
moment of this is when we the ecologist
started paying attention and we've
declared that the moment in time that
we're going to try to preserve and it it
forgets that environments change and the
devolution happens and it's a pretty
naive view of nature that said invasive
species are real and when it is humans
with our modern technology who are
moving things around the world either
intentionally or not and bringing them
into environments where they have no
native competitors or pathogens or
predators allowing them to take off and
become monocultures to the benefit of
nothing but those species there's a
problem and you've you've rendered
ecosystems unhealthy yeah this is
another thing I covered in in my
dissertation we have a problem that is
very serious with what are called
invasive species one has to be careful
not to declare anything that shows up in
someplace where it didn't exist before
invasive because that's not what they
are there are ornamentals there are
non-native species but invasive well and
you've got all predictive paradigm as to
which which ornamentals for instance are
likely to escape from their ornamental
status and become invasive versus
stay in a garden and be just fine yeah
and I would also say that in traveling
the world the the devastation of
habitats that comes from invasive
species is
absolutely jaw-dropping my least
favorite creatures on earth are probably
trees in the eucalyptus family because
they have absolutely devastated habitats
in California in fact along the whole
west coast of the US the Andes are
utterly transformed by them where
eucalyptus is everywhere and the native
trees that were there are found mostly
in in places where they've been
cultivated it's so destructive so just
to be clear eucalyptus is native to
Australia it doesn't it does it didn't
start out in the new world at all it was
humans who brought it to the new world
and it spread so fast it spreads so it
is simply a superior competitor and the
I think the answer you're looking for
whether you want to hear it or not is
that the problem is there's a trade-off
between competitive ability and
dispersal ability and so the limits of
where things are found are very often
structured by that very ferocious
competitors are often limited in where
they can get and so when we transport
something like eucalyptus what we were
effectively doing is saying let every
habitat be dominated by the same
critters and what that means is an
overall loss in the diversity of
critters around and I don't know live in
a less diverse world for lots of reasons
having everything to do with human
utility and well-being I want to live in
a highly diverse world and so if I want
to live in a highly diverse world the
invasive species are among the greatest
threats because once Unleashed it's
almost impossible to do anything about
them if they're really good competitors
like eucalyptus then you know a single
error where they get released is out of
control almost instantly how does how
does fungi reprogram ant brains it's fun
it's a good question I don't I don't
know how it does it I don't think
anybody does yeah but what I can say is
that the real question is how do ant
brains work and the itself is I mean so
they they have
don't they a bunch of ganglia so they
don't have a centralized brain they have
I think I thinkwell have at the very
least they don't have something that we
would all agree as a brain but they do
have neurological processing that
results in coordinated behavior and in
order to understand how a fungus
intervenes to get a creature to behave
in this way you probably have to realize
what heuristics are running about inside
an ants head which I don't think we know
but lots of you know to the extent that
rabies causes you know anger and an
infected dog that causes the dog to
behave in a way that spreads the rabies
it's the same kind of process but maybe
it's easier to understand in a dog how
you would trigger anger because lots of
things confusion because we know that
mammals experience these kinds of
emotions because we're mammals yeah so
it's harder it's harder to understand
what seems like a complex behavioral
response in an organism that we don't
think of as having individually complex
behavior yep all right please can you
discuss alright switch it out please can
you same question no okay
the invasive species question again I
think we did it
did you see the videos regarding Philly
Metro personnel and security
aggressively kicking people off for
failure to wear masks this is from Jonas
apologize if I'm mispronouncing your
name someone we know on Twitter didn't I
don't see these videos I didn't either
yeah well I don't know what to say I
didn't see the video so I don't know
whether it would be obviously beyond the
pale or you know justified but I can say
I have watched a radical transformation
in how what percentage of people are
wearing some kind of mask and I regard
that as on the one hand very good news
people are taking this seriously and on
the other hand how many people are going
to die because other people were afraid
to stand out right in other words if you
weren't wearing a mask because
other people weren't wearing masks and
you'd feel dumb wearing a mask or
somebody hadn't given you the kind of
license you would need to innovate some
kind of a mask then other people were
put at risk and so what I hope is that
next time we will remember that we all
ended up wearing the masks and we will
be able to jump to it and you know a lot
of lives could be saved yeah the biggest
expert the biggest expert in a research
area usually has the most motivation to
dishonestly kill work that is disruptive
true how is it that this obvious
conflict of interest is overlooked when
a paper is assigned reviewers yeah well
let's just be clear assigned reviewers
is already the problem the idea that the
field has the right to kill off concepts
because they're not high quality doesn't
make any sense it made sense maybe in a
world where ink and paper were limited
and you had to figure out on what to
spend them but we are now talking about
pixels pixels are not expensive if you
want to put out an idea that everybody
thinks is stupid well let's let you put
it out and if you turn out to be right a
hundred years from now we can come back
to it and we can say well we got that
wrong so what where's the harm in it so
let's just do the process of reviewing
other people's work in public where the
people who turn out to be right
especially people who turn out to be
right and way ahead of their time are
ultimately vindicated and the people who
we thought were experts who turn out to
be wrong again and again and again
stopped being listened to so there are
going to be one piece of pushback there
is going to be you know everyone
complains about review or two three
three papers the three reviewers and
it's always reviewer two comes up with
the most ridiculous arguments against
the paper but in general what those
three reviewers peer reviewers on any
paper are supposed to be doing is
looking at different aspects of the
paper so for it so if this is all to
happen in public very few people have
equal facility and say assessing whether
or not the theoretical framework for a
paper makes sense
and
is actually building on the thing that
the authors are claiming and whether or
not the experimental design and the
prediction and the hypothesis that is
being tested is actually being tested
with this experimental design whether or
not the predictions inherently follow
from the hypothesis so it's a second
realm data analysis is a hugely
technical realm and most of the people
who can do that really relish
statisticians who don't necessarily have
the chops to do the hypothesis
assessment and experiment design
assessment and I would say you don't it
is useful to feel to know that someone
with the chops that you don't have has
looked at a paper and said yep that
passes muster over in my end of things
especially now with the ridiculously
complicated statistics the people are
using often to cover their tracks but
sometimes because the data really are
really do call for complicated
statistics yes
but again and I really want to emphasize
if you have some kind of scientific
background whether its formal or not you
just have an interest and you've spent
some time thinking about it check out
what's going on with the papers that are
emerging every day on kovat 19 and the
lectures that are being delivered on
YouTube by one professional to others we
are this is happening in real time and
it's happening the way actual progress
happens which is to say people are
disagreeing with each other in public
they're taking a stand I believe that
this disease is progressing this way
because of these things that I've
observed know I've observed these other
things and the point is when it plays
out in public like that a it has a much
higher tendency to be honorable where
you're playing with your own reputation
and you're saying no I think it's this
way because of this thing well that's a
risky position to take so anyway I guess
once you start doing this in private and
you have reasons to you know you're
young you're engaged in quality control
I think it's very hard to rescue that
system and the reviewers are anonymous
right so anyway let's just
this in in the open can kovat be
transmitted through farting I haven't
heard anyone say that
mostly when people are farting in public
they've got something covering
themselves right
but given that apparently it is in fecal
matter and it could spread through air I
suppose so
yeah I mean let's put it this way you've
set kind of a low bar for a can it be
yeah like yeah you could probably
generate a scenario on the other hand
it's probably a pretty easy scenario to
prevent from occurring very frequently
yeah though wear underwear yes hey guys
what do you think why do you think
anti-semitism is so persistent it seems
to be rearing its head again at both
ends of the political spectrum yes it
does yeah
yes it does yeah I think well let's put
it this way we don't really have the
bandwidth to do this here but I have
talked elsewhere about the tendency of
human populations to seek different
kinds of growth be it through the
discovery of new lands the discovery of
technologies that allow you to do more
with the lands you already have
available to you and when those things
run out our addiction to growth causes
us to identify populations who can't
protect can't defend what they've got
and to make up reasons to attack them
and so basically anti-semitism comes
down to the fact of Jews being an
unusual population that lives at low
density in many places it's a it's a
diaspora population and not all of it
obviously but a large fraction of it and
so that large fraction is always
vulnerable to the population that isn't
Jewish turning their or turning on them
and so anyway I think it I've my first
evolutionary project actually was a
paper arguing that anti-semitism evolves
and that it has to be stopped that it's
basically a rationalization
or lineage against lineage genocide or
warfare and that is frankly not that
hard to understand good we're gonna try
to be a little speedier speedier yeah
all right a bunch no more adverbs what
are your thoughts on ubi and the issues
it is trying to solve all there are
alternative solutions to those issues go
alright
ubi I am annoyed that this couldn't be
discussed ten years ago
somehow people had to lots of us may
have been involved in a discussion about
the fragility of the system and the
danger of people's incomes being
dependent on certain things suddenly you
be I became discussable because people
who were powerful started talking about
it that's too bad that it required that
but okay I don't think it's a great
solution I think it's a kludge and it
addresses a real problem and it's better
than no solution but I think we have to
address the underlying issue that causes
us to engage ubi as a solution and I
must say in the era of kovat 19 I think
we are finally we have a circumstance
that is finally forcing us to understand
that a system built around economic
efficiency is a fragile system and as
you know so even the Trump
administration is talking about a
stimulus package in which they're going
to infuse cash by delivering it to
people who are now suddenly in dire
straits so you know this has gone from
an idea that was undiscussables
anywhere to an idea that's being
discussed you know at the at the head of
the Republican Party so anyway let us
learn the lesson of this so that we can
get to a better discussion next time
which is if you bi is no good what would
be good
Nate writes again to say thanks that
clears up my confusion of models a bit
good welcome total US dust from flu and
pneumonia the last bad flu year were
about sixty five thousand deaths this
year since Kovan nineteen from non kovin
flu pneumonia effectively zero i'm not
sure that's true but but lower than
expected how
question mark well part of it is that
social distancing for covin 19 works
just as effectively and probably more
effectively against other viruses that
don't have quite as high
transmissibility so we're doing all of
the things that we should have been
doing all along
much more so right but being very
careful to wash our hands and think
about putting our hands on our faces
after we've been touching receipts and
and frequently used surfaces and the
social distancing is far more than any
society could put up with for years and
years and years and years but maybe we
can learn from this the parts of this
that are not that hard to maintain and
they would actually solve will save many
many lives and also just many many sick
days yep
get her here all right I'm being told
Zach you forgot my two super check
questions from this week beginning of
chat + one from last week we're now
thanks to you all you are very inspiring
I said we are now using a app which is
doing it ok I don't know if you guys
could hear that if they call if they
show up before what did you say before
we're live before we're live then they
don't get logged by the app apologies
for that the character this is just a
description of the character limit is
based on how much you pay in super chat
two dollars fifty characters five
dollars hundred fifty characters etc
okay thank you the impact of the virus
will more than likely be devastating to
the existing economic model could this
crisis facilitate a radical rethink the
monetary system that is a good we were
just there yes and it must it must if
this isn't the wake-up call then the
wake-up call may be too devastating for
us to recover from yep exactly
love you too Brett your story on Eric's
Chan was yeah how there I was frustrated
by the fact that nobody in the public
sphere would speak of gametes you were
the first person who ever used that word
in public where presumably we're talking
about
what makes sex what what the actual most
fundamental definition of biological sex
is there are lots and lots of indicators
from primary and secondary sex
characteristics to differences in brain
structure to genitals to chromosomes in
the case of mammals and birds and a few
other organisms but it's gametes that's
a distinction so thank you Gaming size
and motility yeah so if you have if you
are and we've we've said this elsewhere
and and I have to if you are a biologist
in the field and you discover a new
species and it somehow you just you've
no idea what's going on with it and
there's plenty of species out there
where you can't tell if you know
typically are behaviorally if they're
male or female if you find that one of
them that one individual has gametes
that are large ish larger than average
cells within that within that organism
and sessile don't tend to move and
that's a female you got in your hands
and if you have gametes that are very
small stripped of cytoplasm and tend to
be speedy at least in some parts of
their lifecycle
there you have a male so sperm or pollen
being the animal and plant versions of
the male gametes and eggs being a female
and yeah it really does it really does
make it simple yeah it is just the
fundamental underlying what the
distinction is let's see is it possible
to detect a less lethal mutation right
now and try to purposefully spread that
mutation this is in effect hmm I want to
I want to go that far I've been toying a
lot with the question about sub-lethal
infections here and one of the questions
which I really I would love to hear
somebody who's well-versed in this who
knows the answer if it was true that
infections that do not that are
asymptomatic are not destructive and not
frequently transmitted which is
plausible because it is the distress
that causes symptoms and it is also it's
the lesions that are spilling virus into
your lungs or wherever that are causing
the transmission so if it were true that
an asymptomatic case was not destructive
to your body or not very destructive to
your body and not highly transmissible
then in effect it functions like a
vaccine if on the other hand it is true
and the virus wins in a way it slows
down its rate of spread but it also
never ends up in a host it dies well and
this is we've been saying since our
first live stream that there tends to be
an evolution towards a lower virulence a
lower virulence lower damage infection
over time and this would be that
accelerating so you know the virus
doesn't want to make you sick it wants
to be passed on to the extent that want
is a fair shorthand here and so to be
passed on a symptomatically would be
fine and anyway there's a question about
whether or not the host is the place
where this evolution takes place which i
think in general that is but there will
also be some evolution on the part of
the the viruses and to the extent that
less lethal ones spread it is likely to
our benefit but you know I don't know I
don't know where we are and I'd love to
know what is true in these asymptomatic
cases respected damage and you know in
and further infections we need so much
more information than we have know is
hydrochloric win and I had said
hydrochloric won at one point I and I
think it's actually hydroxychloroquine I
think I said Hydra clerk when are you
corrected me but I had in an earlier
episode I think with hydrochloric so I
put that in your head is a drug see
chloroquine used to essentially keep the
body from burning itself up it regulates
the immune system from swaying out of
balance correct question mark I don't
know that I would characterize it that
way but I don't know what exactly it's
either it tends to do in the case of
malaria nor do I know what it is what we
think it's mechanism of action against
kovat 19 is yeah I think that I want to
look this one up and figure out if we
can say something can
nice about it next time okay thanks
Brett and Heather for the engaging
content you're making the isolation very
stimulating you're welcome
do you have plans for an evolutionary
lecture series maybe uh yeah I would say
we have plans probably after our book
emerges I think we will endeavor to get
to put some flesh on those bones yeah
good
what about wim HOF voluntary act quotes
voluntary activation of the sympathetic
nervous system and attenuation of the
innate immune response in humans as a
method to not overreact to virus we've
got a couple questions about wim HOF
maybe the first Q&A that we did
yep and neither of us looked into it
afterwards we both had some exposure I
looked into it a little but not enough
to say yet I'm still I'm still curious
about what he's still a possibility and
I think it is what what Jamie Jamie will
yeah
and you know he he he Jamie knows what
he's doing and I you know I trust that
if he thinks that something is valuable
it probably has at least some value to
it yep okay um kovat released on purpose
says who Thanks
I think what we said last time was that
it seemed unlikely this was released on
purpose and likely that this was
released by accident from a laboratory
in Wuhan yep but but it's open yeah we
don't know does the current working
assumption that this is not a bioweapon
prevent treatment protocols to be more
flexible and limit the research focus
thank you my assumption from the
beginning has been there comes a point
if this was a weapon
then it would predict certain things
about it but until we have evidence that
positively suggests that it is actually
a weapon that it doesn't add anything we
would do the same thing yeah at a
epidemiological level and so again I
want to see the evidence that says it's
worth our time to pursue the this is a
bioweapon line of inquiry and until I
see that my sense is
I don't want to get distracted by it
yeah we're drowning in a sea of
misinformation and under information and
trying to imagine all the possible ways
that you know like a switch could have
been built into this if it was a bio
weapon that could change what it's doing
like who knows it's an infinite it just
opens up the those possibilities to
infinity and we already don't have
enough we already can't limit the
degrees of freedom enough yeah watch all
your vids keep it up if you can thank
you carbon monoxide therapy for kovat
patients I can't find out if anyone has
tried this clinically I was reading on
the connection with malaria vaccines
enough vaccines and stumbled across
fascinating legette research so again if
you are referring to fascinating legit
research link it here or find some other
way to link it I don't know carbon
monoxide therapy seems sounds very
dangerous so my understanding that
carbon monoxide binds hemoglobin better
than oxygen and co2 thus displacing them
yeah so I can easily imagine you making
a case of kovat 19 vastly worse on the
other hand you would need to I mean if
it was like a way of pulling out the
hemoglobin that's been attacked and then
simultaneous with blood transfusion from
health yeah I wouldn't want anybody who
didn't know what they were doing
experimenting with yeah carbon monoxide
yeah why isn't the dorfmann method used
anywhere I don't know yeah I don't know
why isn't dorfman method used anywhere
what's the dorfmann method what is the
Dorf I'm glad you well no chalk board
okay I don't know what the Dorfman
method is so yeah it doesn't really
matter even though you don't know what
it is yeah do you have the uncut
Weinstein versus Dawkins debate Pangburn
version deceptively edits out all the
parts where you school Dawkins tons of
missing film
I don't think Pangburn did that
intentionally Pangburn was I believe
being a cheapskate and decided not to
actually record the thing properly and
it was being recorded on a handycam now
if I had known that that was the case I
would have had somebody in the audience
record it but I didn't
that was the case until a fragmented
partial video was released and so the
only hope I think is the venue may have
recorded it and I have called them up
and tried to find out and I've gotten
nowhere but if the Chicago Theatre has a
copy maybe somebody here knows somebody
at the Chicago theater who could dredge
it up I would be forever grateful yeah
it'd be great we don't have it and as
far as we know penguin doesn't have it
either and no it does it doesn't seem
like that was intentional on his part
just cheap skater II yeah please read my
two questions the being of this chat we
just don't have them man if they started
before regarding athletics and exercise
how does the impact of tearing down
muscle apply to cellular senescence does
the speed up the aging process I'm so I
think I know what this question is about
yeah there's long been evidence that
athletic activity does not advance
senescence which is at first pass
paradoxical because it involves some
wear and tear on the other hand muscle
is an unusual tissue because it's
multinucleate and so the tendency for
cellular reproduction to runaway in
muscle at least striated muscle is
greatly reduced but there may be other
pathologies that look like it so I don't
know the answer to the question but
let's just say first step would be
recognizing that skeletal muscle is
distinct in its cellular nature and
therefore doesn't fit in the same
trade-off matrix or it doesn't fit in
the same way all right could you talk
about Gilbert's syndrome why it was
selected for and how it's linked to
hemoglobin could relate to Koba 19 wow I
don't know what Gilbert's syndrome is II
I am far better versed in sullivan
syndrome sorry I don't mean reserve now
we just wait I mean there's just two
very quickly that we don't we don't
don't know what it is
do antibodies to antibodies after
infection mean immunity okay so this is
written interestingly I don't know if
you can see it do antibodies after
infection mean immunity over inability
to infect others over inability to
become reinfected I'm not I'd say it's
slashes right yeah but there's also fits
all of these three things fancy
parentheses and those three things are
immunity immunity inability to infect
others and inability to become
reinfected oh okay I got it
so do if you have antibodies after
infection does that mean these three
things doesn't mean you are immune that
you cannot infect others and you cannot
become reinfected
we think so yes oh it's something
anybody's right if if you test positive
for a serology tests actually antibody
test the presence of your antibodies
indicate that well the presence of
antibodies says you were exposed yes if
exposure you've had a strong enough
immune response to producing a body's
yeah if your immune response is the
result of having been infected what we
assume and I think now have pretty good
evidence we don't see a lot of double
infections people who recover and then
get sick again we've seen none there are
a couple of cases that Nicholas
Christakis was talking about early on
that he thinks were due to the problem
of false negatives right that people
appeared to have been recovered tested
negative and then tested positive again
but probably just hadn't had not
recovered yet
but the short answer those aren't
serology tests those were antigen test
PCR tests yeah the mechanism is what are
called memory cells and at some point I
think I'm gonna put together a lecture
on how the immune system works it's one
of the most stunning things I've ever
heard and it's well worth exploring at
an evolutionary level but the thing is
your body fights an infection at the as
its fighting it has effectively an army
of cells that are specifically targeted
at the infectious agent and it fights
this battle and eventually if you don't
die of it it wins when it wins that army
edit
down and you create what are called
memory cells in these memory cells
remember the formula for defeating that
enemy and so if you are challenged with
another particle a viral particle that's
close enough then the infection never
gets far enough for you to detect that
you had another encounter so it's those
memory cells that would do it so in
order to get to the three things were
you can't be infected again
you can't infect others and what was the
third one and you are immune I guess in
some ways that's the same yes the same
one and three are the same thing so the
answer is if the if the virus doesn't
evolve too quickly then probably having
had it once is enough to prevent you
from ever getting it again because your
memory cells will persist and they will
spot it the next time it shows up and at
the point that you fully recover unless
it's one of these viruses that retreats
to some tissue which I think we would
also know that already do you think yeah
because I think we'd see some
recurrences that wouldn't make sense
unless it's a longer term re-emergence
oh yeah five acts malaria well my guess
is wait for months or years yeah I don't
think but again that's that's malaria
it's not a virus but there are viruses
to do it and I just don't know that we
have seen a corona virus that does this
so in other words it's resident in a
population but it's not that it hides in
a tissue of an individual so assuming
you beat the pathogen you're free of
active particles hiding out in some
tissue and you have memory cells that
can spawn it than all three of those
conditions will obtain which may
actually be two conditions yeah a study
shows SARS two effects a stew in testes
decreasing testosterone with elderly
compromised unhealthy and dense groups
thoughts on depopulation well if it's
affecting the elderly it's not going to
have much of an effect yep and you know
it it it does it clearly is affecting or
it's killing men and making higher rates
than it's killing women and it's making
men sicker when they do get sick then
it's making women but men aren't the
limit on population size
so it's unlikely to affect population
yep clothes get darker when wet because
of like light trapping see do I also is
dyslexia an evolutionary adaptation mmm
all right let's talk dyslexia here's the
thing dyslexia is a kind of a garbage
category that covers all sorts of things
that interfere with what is considered
normal reading in my opinion it's not
really a disability because reading is
too new in other words to say that
somebody like me is I'm not against
being defective but in this case to say
that somebody like me who has challenges
when reading is defective pays no heed
to the fact that reading at a maximum
goes back 8,000 years and wasn't a
common feature of a human existence
until a few hundred years ago and so we
basically are not evolutionarily
prepared for it
so what I would say is it is a novelty
problem where reading is novel you
probably have a bail distribution of you
know how good you are at reading and
there's some arbitrary threshold at
which we decide that your reading is
compromised enough that you have a some
kind of a failure a system failure but
that that's arbitrary and my argument
would be everybody is dyslexic when
they're tired or their glasses are dirty
you know or there's loud music playing
right there's lots of things that can
interfere and some of us are just
dyslexic at 12-point font
under decent lighting and so it gets
noticed and being an imperfectly matched
for the dominant paradigm allows you to
forces you to do n runs around the
dominant paradigm and thus find
solutions elsewhere so as we've talked
about elsewhere dyslexia is one of these
I don't think of myself as doing n runs
again around the dominant paradigm I
think if my self as running circles
around the dominant paradigm yes you do
yes you are but autism spectrum
colorblindness
left-handedness there are all sorts of
these things where there is a dominant
way of being and if you are somewhere
outside of that dominant way of being
you're forced into solution making that
looks different and it often ends up
resulting in pretty heterodox thinking
can the earth be considered an organism
or super organism from an evolutionary
biological perspective no it's too flat
can it be considered an organism no
that's not an organism no nor is it a
super organism nope
just like forests don't evolve the earth
doesn't evolve we have shared fate here
on the earth but that does not mean that
it is an organism or a super organism my
previous question and I don't know which
that was was intent to discover whether
you believe it is possible that non
kovat flu and pneumonia deaths are being
counted as covin oh yeah it's possible I
think there's not a ton of it probably
going on but it's certainly possible
that some are although I think it's
almost certain that some are by virtue
of the fact that you have everything
through asymptomatic cases of kovat and
so people come into the hospital and you
die it's gonna be classified as we
happen but we don't know how we don't
know whether it's enough to make a dent
in what we think is going on or if it's
just the rare case but it's certain not
to be zero right good is there
compromise between protection for Cova
19 while allowing the economy to work
perhaps continue telecommute
mask-wearing distancing in public places
but let work continue yeah yes and there
so far I see almost no economies no
nation states making plans and there is
reference to what South Korea did which
was pretty damn effective but there is
such a paucity of testing in the US and
Europe anyway that what are we supposed
to do before we know what percentage of
the populace has been infected and
therefore what the actual case fatality
rate is yeah it's high transmissibility
if the case fatality rate is ten times
the flu but not 100
the flu it's a totally different
landscape have 2% of the US population
at this point been exposed and infected
or 20% or 50% we have no idea fine now
we've got to find out and it seems like
that just I hate it when people make
these arguments but it just doesn't seem
like it should be as hard as it seems to
be yes I would also say we should figure
out how to be surgical about what work
we stopped and what work we allow even
if it doesn't come into play here even
if we were on the verge of a
breakthrough and I must say at the
vaccine if it comes is going to be a
long way off I've now seen proper
analysis that suggests that but whatever
the mechanism that gets us through kovat
19 this is probably not the last time we
will face it and so figuring out how
work continues without allowing an
epidemic to continue spreading manure
that out now it's not going to get
easier and this is this is our moment
because we've already done a lot of the
heavy lifting yeah and I don't know how
other places how other jurisdictions are
defining essential services but you know
in in Portland anyway and I think I
assume throughout the state of Oregon
hardware stores are open nurseries are
open Landscaping Supply places are open
and for us this means that we can you
know we're still you know stuck and
there's tremendous amount of restriction
in terms of what we can do but we are
able to continue to do a lot of work in
and around our house that you know could
have easily been delay into for you know
months or years and so you know in what
way is a nursery an essential service
you you can't make that argument from
the perspective of you know I'll die if
I don't have this plant on the other
hand for those people who do spend time
outside and plant their own plants it is
potentially a difference between coming
out of the psychologically intact and
not yep how many more do we have we have
okay good no I see closer to ten but oh
maybe it's not let's see sorry I'm
trying to figure out where I was
previously you spoke of kovat being able
to switch its behavior to mutate more
easily
what possible mechanism could do this
and be accurate
well mutation generally isn't accurate
unless the mutations would cause it to
fail and then those very very mutations
that worked would would be selected for
and proceed yep a facultative program
that allowed greater variation when
something told some strain of the virus
that it was in a cul-de-sac
it could be advantageous not saying it
happens but it's possible absolutely can
you explain if it is possible for the
virus to have spread from a bat biting
an animal that was then consumed by
humans we don't know but it's certainly
plausible hmm it's pretty unlikely for
one thing we're talking about a
horseshoe bat but but again you know is
it might be zero but it's possibly not
zero much more likely that a bat I mean
especially if this thing is depleting
oxygen capacity either by messing up the
lungs or messing with the hemoglobin a
bats gonna suffer from that very quickly
because of the way in which oxygen is
used so a sick bats not gonna last very
long mm unless this thing is at a really
really low level which is also possible
or somehow it manifests quite
differently in different hosts yep
different host species like it's always
asymptomatic in bats right we die which
is possible but I would also argue that
that's gonna come with low
transmissibility you know if the if the
bat is biting yeah that the biting thing
here horseshoe bats don't tend to
horseshoe bat biting a Pangolin would be
quite a natural history scenario right
on the other hand falling out of the sky
because it's sick and couldn't make it
back and some animal trundling along and
happening on to it is possible on the
other handle don't they they do on the
other hand the the wet market connection
is looking very tenuous to me I did I
started to do some looking into the
distribution of bats around Wuhan I'm
having I'm having trouble buying that
this was the wet market I think it's
much more likely the virology lab all
right interesting
please let us know buyed thank you by
the way if you'll consider questions
asked before left like next time okay
so we'll try to figure that out sure
okay yes we will also watch out for BOTS
thank you I don't know how to pronounce
your name uh Co for the Dorfman method
is group testing combining samples to
one repeat our PCP our test why isn't it
used anywhere that gets us a little bit
closer but I still don't really know
what it's what it's referring to sorry
thank you both for your work you're
welcome
possible evidence of tissue retreat okay
so there's a link here we'll take a look
three more questions can you guys give
us a tour of your house video we don't
have a house and if we did it would be
on VHS and you just like look at it
there you go yeah
I don't know that's kind of a
frightening prospect but we'll think
about yeah maybe we'll give you a tour
of three corners three well-chosen
corners of this confusing question for
episode 4 could an organism carry a
benign virus that kills predators any
known examples presumably a virus would
function like toxin yeah I don't know
yeah examples of that I will repeat what
I said last time which is that the
problem with this is an evolutionary
mechanism is it the best deal if you had
a virus the Predators
feared irrationally let's say you would
have to have some sort of an
advertisement that you had the virus in
order for predators to know to avoid you
but then the best deal is to use the
advertisement and not have the virus at
all and so until you can get an honest
advertisement of the virus I don't see
how it could evolve yeah okay two more
questions and then we are done do you
believe that homo sapiens are the final
carbon-based life-form in our
evolutionary lineage well yes unless we
figure some [ __ ] out pretty quickly here
yeah and we could declare ourselves you
know we could declare our children a new
the the problem is
the term species has these two different
meanings right and so creatures in a
sequence are different we can declare
our kids a new species and because it's
not the same criteria you would use to
separate to bat species let's say to Co
coexisting bat species yeah but he says
in our evolutionary lineage he makes a
point of not saying species so you know
we right that's my point is our lineage
is continuing at least another
generation yeah so I don't know how to
answer the question okay one more
question is it possible that the
functionality of the memory cells is
being hijacked by kovat and causing them
to initiate hemolysis that's how that's
pronounced right hemolysis subsequently
releasing ferritin and kicking off an
aisle 6 cytokine storm
well the cytokine storm has been
observed as a I don't know what the
proper term would be but a major
correlate of the worst cases of kovat 19
yeah so I find it it's boy I don't I
don't want to define it because I I will
I will screw it up and then I will end
up having to make another correction
next time but so cytokine storm yes as
for the several links in the chain you
described don't know enough to say I
will say that there are two
possibilities what was I reading it had
to do with whether or not Cova dean was
attacking the immune system which would
be a very frightening prospect that's
what aids does is AIDS or HIV attacks
the activated t-cells and then the
alternative possibility was don't have
it I don't have it but it looked like it
was not attacking the immune cells
specifically so you know who knows that
evidence will develop again I've now got
a bunch of things I need to look into
but I will see if I can't come up with
the particular paper I was looking at
and pass it along next time
okay one more question and then we're
out all right has any of you have any of
you spoken with Paul Stamets could
mushrooms play a role in resolving Coppa
19 no one by reputation but not the man
yeah um don't know if he's working on
something
a fellow greener though he's a he's a
fellow greater fellow greener so anyway
yeah I don't know he seems to find
mushrooms have utility and lots of
things so are we always shocked but
anyway Paul if you got something and
contact us that's right all right
all right well this has been harrowing
with all of the technical failures thank
you for sticking with it and I think we
will try to compile these together in
some way we will upload a final with all
of them together or a pair in any case
we will edit out the catastrophes um we
will see you next time hopefully we'll
have our technical difficulties ironed
out fully by then back on Tuesday 3:30
p.m. Pacific okay stay safe